where do you stand on elon's effect on
bitcoin and cryptocurrency in general
these days
i believe that bitcoin is a massive
breakthrough for the human race that
will cure half the problems in the world
and generate hundreds of trillions of
dollars of economic value to the
civilization
and i believe that um
it's an early stage
where many people don't understand it
and they're afraid of it and there's fud
and there's uncertainty there's doubt
and there's fear
and there's a very noisy crypto world
and there's 15 000 other cryptos that
are are seeking relevance
and i think most of the fud
uh is actually fueled by the other
crypto entrepreneurs so the
environmental fund and the other types
of of uncertainty that surround bitcoin
generally
they're not coming from legitimate
environmentalists they don't come from
legitimate uh
critics they actually are guerrilla
marketing campaigns
that are being financed and fueled by
other crypto
entrepreneurs because they have an
interest in doing so
so
if i look at the constructive path
forward
first i think it'd be very constructive
for corporations to embrace bitcoin
and build applications on top of it
you don't you don't need to fix it
there's nothing wrong with it right like
when you put it on a layer two and a
layer three it moves a billion times a
second at the speed of light so every
beautiful cool defy application
every crypto application everything you
could imagine you might want to do you
can do
with a legitimate company
and a legitimate website or mobile
application sitting on top of bitcoin or
lightning
if you want to
so i think that um
to the extent that people do that that's
going to be better for the world
if you consider what holds people back i
think it's just misperceptions
about what bitcoin is so i'm a big fan
of just uh educating people if
if you're not if you're not going to
commercialize it then just educate
people on what it is so for example
bitcoin's the most efficient
use of energy in the world by far
right most people don't they don't
necessarily perceive that or realize
that but if you were to take any metric
energy intensity
you put like two billion dollars worth
of electricity in the network every year
and it's worth 850 billion dollars there
is no industry in the real world
right that that is that energy efficient
not only that energy efficient it's also
the most sustainable industry we just
we do surveys 58
of bitcoin mining energy is sustainable
so there's a very uh good story in fact
every other industry planes trains
automobiles construction food medicine
everything else
it's less clean
less efficient
so
so the basic debate would like to i
wouldn't say there is a debate i would
just say that to the extent that the
bitcoin community had any issue with
elon it was just you know the just this
environmental
you know
uncertainty that he fueled in a couple
of his tweets
right
uh which i think just is very
distracting
well that was one of them but i think
it's like the bitcoin maximalist but
general the crypto community what you
call the the crypto entrepreneurs
are
you know it's also
they're using it for
i mean
for investment for speculation
and therefore get very passionate about
people's kind of uh
celebrities including you like famous
people right
um saying positive stuff about any one
particular
crypto
thing a thing you can buy in coinbase
and so um they might be unhappy with
elon musk that he's promoting bitcoin
and then not
and promoting dogecoin then not
and this kind of
um
there's so much emotion tied up in the
communication on this topic
and that's i think that's where a lot of
the
look i don't have
i don't have a criticism of elon musk
he's free to do whatever he wishes to do
it's his life in fact elon musk is the
you know the second largest supporter of
bitcoin in the world so i think that the
bitcoin community tends to eat its own
quite a bit yeah it tends to be very
uh very self-critical and instead of
saying
well elon is more supportive of bitcoin
than the other 10 000 people in the
world you know with serious amounts of
money they like they focus upon
you know yeah this is strange
eating your own is just um yeah so i
mean i think he he's free to do what he
wants to do like and i i think he's done
a lot of good for bitcoin in in putting
it on the balance sheet of tesla and
holding it and i think that sent a very
powerful message
you